because i was one of them guys man you
never know which black ozama we're gonna
get and on his day he could win any
tournament here we go guys first or two
action jungle out post two spain versus
france
this is terrifying this is terrifying
okay
all right here we go
we're gonna have the balcony break the
balcony break in play we're also gonna
have a wall break as well this stage is
very unique in that it's in that regard
but it's gonna be asaka versus akuma a
first to action
let's see
fight
i can't call this this is so tight all
of these matches are just
they're getting too too close to call
right now
good doctor super akuma knows that and
that's one thing that superkumar you
know not many people talk about his
ability to like duck strings and punish
his punishment is very solid man but
he's been playing tekken for a very long
time you know like i mean he isn't just
a street fighter player that found kind
of success in tekken he's been playing
tekken since tag two since before akuma
was in the game so and his his name was
super akuma before before tekken 7 even
got announced which is a crazy thing man
what the most amazing foreshadowing you
know
but it's spelled it's from some anime
isn't it
yeah it was like this this dragon ball
bridge thing you know super kami guru
that's where it came from i don't know
why you chose akuma but yeah either way
that's a bit of a superhuman law there
for you guys
there we go
look at this that's the second wall here
a lot of damage there coming out
oh oh nice
yeah knows he can block that last one
but wow
what a high risk play there from black
azama already i mean it is first to two
so uh you know
balls to the wall let's get it out there
man what did you say earlier on swag
throw the kitchen sink out of man see
what happens
uh if we want someone to do that black
zombies your guy man back three gets
punished from super camera rage
available now jumps back
okay oh whoa
oh
what okay totally just got around it but
there wow okay super coma
i think i think the rage art might have
been a good option there from black
summer when you got the wool splat but
yeah managed to to drop that superkima
to your rounds what's up now
oh doesn't get the the full wall under
there very very difficult to get there
and have to stretch
and no punish on the on the fireball
again i believe that asic is up for two
might punish there is -14
yeah
and look as well guys uh we do have uh
bars uh for days here for super akuma
just working on his second one there now
but magic four not converted off by
black kazama 30 seconds left on the
clock you do not want to go down you do
not want to go down three again super
akuma man he will ride that momentum all
the way to the victory
wow big low parry here okay
two bars a meter probably doesn't want
to use him here so he has a safety net
if he loses this but big grab no tech
there super akuma not taking grams today
yeah
uh oh oh two seconds left you can make
the comeback kiss i said two oh
nice that cause i'm clutching out yeah
he used both meters right there um
very very scary stuff here yeah
definitely he he definitely invested in
that round to try and get the to get the
match but
black ozama stays alive
if he wants to make this uh a final
round now is the best opportunity as
there's no meter for super akuma
and that's the breakables there as well
didn't really know what to do kind of a
weird wall splat and just went for that
guaranteed easy damage here yep okay
down threes
demon flips
okay super cool
okay
hold on around it
okay now we've got a game ladies and
gentlemen black kazama super akuma final
round game one
oh good side step on the fireball but no
punish the low whiffs and super kim are
ready for the punish a bar and me are
just built there can you take it to the
wall though yeah oh just shy just shy i
cursed them i cursed them
those moving walls
okay there's the splash
splat here oh gosh a lot of damage
coming out here
oh
why yep you can see it you can see it
seven golden letters
super akuma can see it he's got that
future vision man he knows he knows it's
coming back you know um
really really like solid play there
final round came down to it super akuma
knocks it out with a perfect and super
cool but if he's able to win the next
match
he secures himself a guaranteed first
place here on the toc standings which is
really really big for him here i know he
wants it so this means more than just
progressing on in this master event he
does eliminate any opportunity for
someone to to go up up there right so
you've got tetsu and uh kawis who
currently i don't know if they're in the
top eight standings at the moment which
is why super kuma will guarantee himself
the win uh or the number one spot if
black summer loses now but um
i don't know i think that's that black
because i'm probably gonna go to the
infinite stage now and get rid of those
walls even that last round you saw the
down three into the fireball one two
wool splat i mean it does so much damage
you want to eliminate that if you can uh
from the aquila player yeah absolutely i
mean uh but
this is still my favorite super
equivalent story that he's just he's so
comfortable on the infinite stage now
because people just pick it against him
and so he doesn't he doesn't mind going
to the infinite he's just like okay this
is the combo now that i do i lose you
know 15 damage or 20 damage or whatever
and just because we have to play on an
infinite stage so let's see super kuma
up a game he only needs this one more if
he takes the w here ladies and gentlemen
he is going to uh move on here in the
bracket and yep we have the infinite
stage
all right
just as we thought here we go
it was your semi-final that coveted
grand final is getting closer and closer
ladies and gentlemen
fight moving in all right have you got
straight away back three wow
i remember as as good as you know um
just picking infinite is versus akuma
super kimo told me as well like you know
i know people are gonna pick this stage
versus me but i know my options i'm very
good on the infinite as well i know what
i need to do i cut my combo short again
oh kazemi i know my situation so you
know it's not going to be easy
yeah for anybody out there uh that
doesn't uh no super cool is really good
at tech and not just really good at
akuma um
but i think a lot of people uh used to
say it anyway that he was carried by his
character but nope this guy has
more knowledge of fighting games than
i've ever forgotten so
i should have said it the other way
around actually but here we go look at
this
um
10 seconds left and black ozama big
power crush move there
takes it round one here that's the
second round in a row there and he also
has a bow
that's crazy lovely whipped punch that
was standing too and that's the thing
right if super cool if you don't get the
live feed early on supergirl makes it
very hard for you to make it to make a
comeback oh counter hit there though
okay there's the screw what are you
gonna do oh
he's up on it for some uh some odd oak
semi as you were talking about earlier
on this bag
absolutely here we go five well again
brilliant block super cooler just knows
when to block but not this time catch
some ducky not moving
[Music]
that was a very hard read right there
yeah and you know he could he could
afford to take that because he's one
match up he's one round up as well he
went for the big didn't work out for him
but it's okay we're back in sure
and we should have another barometer
just about now there it is
checking in
um
one more on the round going 40 seconds
voting even on the live lead doesn't get
the unblockable
oh god here it is
1-1
this is all started with that okay it
gets the maximum damage
blakazama needs to do something here but
we've seen it last round with the down
three takes a potential final round for
black kazama here now in the tekken
online challenge
yep that'll be a fourth place finish for
him super kumar can win this round he
secures himself a guaranteed first
position on that leaderboard
he's got a bar as well to work with very
dangerous
out the air okay
not a lot of damage there yeah i was
looking for some sort of reset jank
there
um doesn't get it super kuma knows that
uh he's watched black azama play before
he's played black kazama before yeah
watch the fire though okay it burns it
just looking for that pressure but the
rear
does he know the combo he absolutely
does doesn't end it but doesn't need to
block his ammo holding on to this for
dear life right now still potential
final round of his tournament life are
we going to get us a final game hey nice
parry is guaranteed no
oh he's trying to go for another
reversal but the knee comes out ahead
from super akuma big whiff good punish
doesn't get that punish there very
difficult to punish good sidewalk not
enough though super akuma can still
block it watch that barometer though
he's sitting on it he's sitting on it 35
seconds left all he needs to do is pull
the trigger on it it's been a slow
slower match he managed to float in but
no conversion
okay gonna leave him with rage here
keeps him close looking for that jump in
tech last opportunity now for black
cause i'm a rage available 19 second
left on the clock trying to go for the
mid launcher super cool my defense
holding up
oh
one plus two
ten seconds left on the clock
one more
pixel
oh no
that is gonna be it super akuma
will secure himself a number one spot
down the leaderboard eliminating black
kazama from the west europe masters he
gets a fourth place a very valiant
effort but super creamer stays alive and
moves in the top three